hello everybody I just got off the phone
with vice chairman of the Joint Chiefs
of Staff sandy Winnefeld to get the
latest report on the situation in Fort
put obviously we're following it closely
the situation is fluid right now but my
national security team is in close
contact with not just the Defense
Department but the FBI they are working
with folks on the ground to determine
exactly what happened to make sure that
everybody is secure and I want to just
assure all of us that we are going to
get to the bottom of exactly what
happened you know any shooting is
troubling obviously this reopens the
pain of what happened at Fort Hood five
years ago we know these families we know
they're incredible service to our
country and the sacrifices that they
make obviously our thoughts and prayers
were are with the entire community and
we are going to do everything we can to
make sure that the community at Fort
Hood has what it needs to deal with the
current situation but so any potential
aftermath we're heartbroken that's
something like this
might have happened again and I don't
want to comment on the facts until I
know exactly what has happened but for
now I would just hope that everybody
across the country is keeping the
families and the community of Fort Hood
in our thoughts and our prayers the
folks there have sacrificed so much on
behalf of our freedom many of the people
there have been through multiple tours
in Iraq and Afghanistan they serve with
valor and they serve with distinction
and when they're at their home base they
need to feel safe we don't yet know what
happened tonight but obviously that
sense of safety has been broken once
again and we're going to have to find
out exactly what happened the Pentagon
will undoubtedly have further briefings
for you as we get more details about
what happened alright thanks over